foreign
[Music]
s were fun sorry I just can't take me
seriously
I can't take us seriously
yeah we really went for it
I mean dude we look we look normal like
this is what people do you know
The Uncanny Valley in both of our eyes
do that again go from me to Cody
[Laughter]
that's freaking me the [ __ ] out I know
I was like going through stories and you
put yours on your story I was like I
gotta get out of here
I swiped so fast I can't just the way
our [ __ ] eyes look ahead of me dying
bro it's definitely is a long process
yeah let me say this
in a way
that was sort of a
it was a a sort of Costco sampling of
Coachella what do you mean you gotta see
like a variety of Acts yeah it's like a
little yes exactly which kind of I was
thinking I was like this is the perfect
concert in a way to me it's the perfect
con one song yeah I want to see one song
by every single artist yeah and that's
what it was it was like we got to see
Lil Baby and the AC worked let me just
oh it was blasted yeah it was cold as
[ __ ] yeah it was uncomfortably cold yeah
I would say
um feel bad for all the ladies in there
nipples oh yeah nice dude and we're all
in jackets like yeah so dudes Kelsey's
like yeah yeah
Pink's on
oh we got to see Taylor Swift in person
yeah
which is kind of cool that was cool yeah
oh sorry I just have to point out that
Elena was so cold
I try to warm her up but I put my hand
on the middle of her back and she's like
don't don't she's like I'm gonna pee my
pants
it's just like the hand on the back but
I guess my hand was cold too and she's
been holding her piss because you know
the brakes were so short it came out
just like she's like I'm gonna pee on my
pants [ __ ] serious I'm gonna pee my
pants
saw the back of her anyway all right
cool
yeah
um got got CT Swift Lionel Richie that
was cool Stevie Stevie Wonder
played did a duet with Charlie puth you
know when I got nervous when he stood up
why it's just the way he did it
it's just he's like oh yeah he just
stood I'm just like
and he just started swaying and it
[ __ ] me up because when he did that
um Lionel Richie was next to him and
Lionel like like he was kind of like
clapping in the moment and then he he
sprung to him he's like oh
I just it was like a split second mom
yeah it was really cool to see Stevie
Wonder play yeah really cool what you
know what bug me out too is we were just
staring at the back of his head yeah but
it was his voice also his voice for his
age oh incredible money yeah
money
yeah it was cool it's just interesting
I'm interesting to see kind of how the
sausage is made
yeah well the sausage in this case is
made of t-swift yeah took home some
[ __ ] Awards yeah I was really hoping
someone will go off script
on and just what just do something yeah
just something crazy something wacky
yeah
we didn't get it no
you know what was really dystopian for
me what
was the mentioning of uh the mass
shooting in Colorado yeah I know that I
don't know man
I think it's you know it's good to talk
about yeah as you know but
I always want to bring awareness but
just sandwiched in I totally agree it
was very odd just sort of like because
it was like it was kind of like oh well
this happened last night we got to write
this in where do we put it it felt like
odd Segways yes exactly like just being
like
our hearts go out to the people of
Colorado you know the victims of the
mass shooting at this gay club pop music
has been in gay clubs for you're just
like whoa whoa whoa wait
and I love popping bottles yeah yeah
it's like oh man like right after
I mean there's no I mean we we you know
we know this from like
doing this show and every time there's a
tragedy and we want to talk about it
it's really weird to segue out of that
into something yeah a little bit lighter
you know so it's like and you're on
national TV yeah it's like it's a tough
thing to do but some of those Segways
were like oh that was crazy yeah back to
back like that yeah I just think for
something so horrific they do like the
people in that scenario deserve a bit
more than a talking point I feel
yeah yeah I mean I think it's a
testament to like how often this happens
yeah and how now it's just kind of like
uh once it happens it's a talking point
the next day everyone got to write
something in about it you have to
acknowledge it and then move on and
nothing really changes yeah that was
Grim it's [ __ ] depressing yeah super
dystopian yeah anyways I love pop music
yeah I do love popping bottles though
yeah what else was cool Cardi's showing
up that was a nice little surprise that
was cool
um glorilla wrapping her ass off yep I
do like that song that the [ __ ] the
the is it Bebe rexha that does that I'm
good and I'm feeling all right so she's
going crazy performing that song and
they just have giant images of David
guetta's face yes showing up on all the
screens [ __ ] was hilarious it was too
old to get him off the [ __ ] screen
it's just some random guy no one cares
yeah
yeah but I agree he's a great name and
he's had some fantastic music but seeing
his face just show up on all these
things that's just like his old ass DJ
face I mean he and he's got that weird
sort of like over the collar look yeah
like he looks like a vampire yeah he
looks like a c character on a blade
remake or something like no one will
watch that performance and be like ah
[ __ ] I wish David guetta's face was
gigantic yeah part of this I thought
he's gonna pop out that box same I
thought he was like I couldn't actually
be there
nah but I think that's why they sh they
did it like that because they're like oh
he's not going to be here but we need
his like presence yeah yeah my boy is
working backstage he was
setting up all the gear he's like worked
on every Big Show that's been here
uh in the last like few months he's like
sending me pictures from
the top scaffolding nice he'll be like
yeah
just like some Alpha I should the office
for the day or whatever the [ __ ]
the but the the wiring should they have
to do for those shows like to your point
about the cost is so sketchy oh yeah
can't even imagine yeah Carrie Underwood
like came out from the on these like
crazy tracks is that what you're talking
about yeah yeah that fly track or
whatever it was just floated over the
audience onto the stage yep
yeah yeah pretty crazy he had already
seen the full show because he saw the
full rehearsal however many times
so I thought that part is it's got to be
weird for him yeah just being like Oh
yeah like that day they rehearsed or the
day before or whatever okay there's a
lot of moving Parts they definitely had
to rehearse that yeah true
yeah it was it was cool it was good it
was cool to be there honestly thanks for
having us there yeah
let us uh
yeah let us write for it next year